I heard we should just tell people who
might be joining this livestream what
we're doing um this is reviewing the
design of function text cases which has
been in the system is experimental
function for a while and we're hoping to
make it more robust and polished so okay
yes I mean I guess it's true thing
there's a pure design question because
if you wanted a experimental eyes it 412
we definitely need to sort that out and
then I guess your uncle may be you know
just kind of interest can talk a little
bit about his efforts to well I mean we
were making significantly more robust
with significantly more types what's
happening yes yes yes yes so for that
did you having created the bigger and
said how many sentence do you have ten
minions okay so so what is it much in
here so right now we have current
behavior what's wrong with the current
behavior okay so just to remind it
current behavior you can give a type by
the way we call it forming documentation
not sure it's I mean everybody speaks
about type naturally so maybe we should
change form to type I'm not sure about
that but keep going okay so only one
form when you have lists it acts like an
alternative okay so you see for example
here there's no repetition even though
fox is both a word and a noun yes no
repetition and same when you ask
positions okay so but you can also ask
for property right yep
and so basically by default is like the
property string and there's something
quite strange is now I asked for both
type and string in
for me to understand you know if it was
ya understand there are two different
types so they're different and so those
become separate elements exactly now
it's called type as opposed to form
actually it is called type yes yes let's
see there and the function is called
type yes it's just in the combination
here we call it form and then there's a
bit of a problem here I mean on the
problem but you know you know certainly
nothing to jump in yeah there's two
actually it's trying to create a verb
but whatever and fine why is it okay
it's probably wrong on this one and and
there's two dog yeah
what on earth was it doing up there in
text cases up at the top where you asked
for noun and just gives the wrong answer
that yeah
that's not good okay okay wrong there
okay but yeah so you have this hopefully
is gonna be better in exhaustion you
have this repetition and okay fine and
even here yeah I don't have type
presents and so there's been this kind
of DD duplicate that has been applied
yeah okay that's crazy
let's look at your turn them sir so I
thought I'd see it's pretty simple is
when you have only one type doesn't
change anything when you have to type
it's now an association you know with
the keys being each type of course when
to the type and you can still have the
properties so basically by default
mother Rama dies it doesn't thread
through where those things occurred yes
alternative so if you want to have the
previous behavior I say you can have
something like eternity which is pretty
easy to do you know then you have the
same behavior as before and then what is
cases do with the luster lookup cases
you
it doesn't support a list as a second
argument the list it's pure pattern as a
second argument okay yeah yeah yes
blank or anything it'll say nothing
because it's not it's just looking for
that pattern all right well that's a
pretty reasonable argument for why okay
so you're proposing if there's a list
okay so and why exactly in that in that
second thing that you're showing there
that with several properties the
consistent thing to do it seems to me
will be to have the right-hand side be
an association
whose
inside being in a nation as well that's
what I'm suggesting
yes okay so kind of the transposed
well no I'm saying that there was word
arrow associated string whatever
whatever whatever now if we did that if
you made this into a data set
no what are you doing now No oh really
oh I was suggesting something different
I was suggesting every isn't it the
compromise it isn't that we are I'm
suggesting that there that every word
the right hand side of its of its rule
would be an association just saying a
little the comma one three would turn
into association string arrow the
position arrows
I see okay actually that wouldn't be
right because the list turns into an
association so it's it's similar to what
happens with the this still unnamed
Association building function that goes
from yeah I'm not such a fan of that
why list of strings and because there
will be a lot of repetition and actually
the other one is kind of you know okay
why is it consistent I don't understand
why that's consistent mean if you if you
take that second form there it will make
a nice yeah I'm saying word goes to a
list of associations now and those two
lists of associations so I think in
terms of a data set that will be
something quite reasonable yeah what
about having the transpose of this I so
instead of a list of Association and my
association of lists yeah I think that
would make more sense but I mean more
not more sense how these things are
gonna be used and I think that's what we
need to look at yes yes okay so let's
look at your compromise solution and
then let's go back no actually actually
no there's no compromise we decided
against it okay
the salaat provisionally lightest weight
yeah I night it just doesn't very
follows it follows well it's different
thing right special case this is Georgia
type yeah it follows the structure of
look I think it's a question of the use
cases what will you use this for I mean
think about the code that goes through
and takes you know the string and it
does I mean you know let's say for
example let's write highlighting code
let's imagine were writing highlighting
code okay yep yeah so there what we're
gonna end up doing is taking every noun
for example and sorry okay fine to do it
do it to it compute that it's not worry
about that okay so now but now what you
want well actually for highlighting you
just need to know the positions yep so
let's say now a narrow position no no
now in our position okay so now it'll be
some kind of I don't even know how you
do that because you know we've got to
put styles around those things but
that's just a string right now yes that
would be that would be putting into
words as well what do you mean I guess
you would split it into words and then
just styling the word I don't think you
can style something inside a string well
you can but it's not an easy thing to do
I mean you can using style boxes and
things it will change their character
positions and so on a weird way
otherwise it would be get the word
actually
no that's no big others positions to the
words extract okay it's gonna be a
string takes yeah okay so an interesting
question let's say you done text words
before you ran text cases okay so take
take a look at what happens there text
would be okay before on fox when the
brown thing whatever it is okay now say
text cases of that common noun text
cases of that list oh no this one works
oh yeah no no try it try it try it
completely crazy it's completely crazy
context but the question is should text
cases in that case treat that as a
single you know treat that as something
where all the pieces are together or
should it no I think it should I think
it should map and yeah in order to be
listed or in order to be able to send a
lot of text and it's just fine but it's
only list of all in the first argument
right yes okay let's keep going because
I want to understand more use cases
because right now that highlighting well
you've got higher estrin okay so here I
will do string take right something like
that does it work yeah so it would be to
be a string take you know up to 21 no
this is absolutely grotesque what's got
to happen here
I mean it's a kind of weird fold of a
string take
know what you forget is to get extract
this part extract this part extract this
part so it would take drop of that list
I think it should be a you should be
able to do a string take of a multi-line
57 in the and the second argument of
string take yeah yeah okay now say
string take drop try to string take drop
do we have that well take drop we server
here look update drop - yeah but I don't
know what happens if you give it if you
give it multiple elements
take and the second argument of take
drop I don't know what it does but this
particular thing of string take drop I
mean this is an operation that we're
going to want to do right that is you've
got some special pieces of the this is
reminiscent of sequence alignment where
and I'm not I've never been very happy
if you look up a sequence alignment up
sequence alignment okay so you see what
that's doing that's got a list where
some elements are just plain strings and
other elements are multi are lists there
that indicates the different things that
are on the different you know pieces of
DNA or whatever know what I'm saying so
that's a case where so in this case what
we really want for this highlighting
thing is something analogous to that
that is some kind of list where you're
going along and then somehow I mean I
would have thought that text element is
the thing that we should be putting in
there that we should have a way of
taking the strengths and decorating it
with text element yeah when I'm saying
other we've got some background might be
great together with us
okay all right for these I mean in
practice what we do is flatten of this
and then add you know prepend
yeah yeah this is totally grotesque one
append minus one thing oh yeah this
minus one do as well and then partition
oh come on come on come on come on going
well yeah of course it will work right
okay so let's go back okay yeah okay so
what you're describing there okay first
question is how do we annotate you know
what
what does
annotated text look like and the answer
is something with text element
presumably yes that's how we're doing
annotation so it should be the case that
something like text cases is capable I
mean text cases is more like pull out
you know like I've got a document show
me all the countries in this document
okay a different issue would be show me
the document with countries highlighted
yes yes yes yes that's actually actually
we thought about doing something for
text cases we haven't thought about
design yet but it is in fan textual
answer already
what so how does highlighted string work
that what is the natural return so here
what
vintage that is not an English that is
not a correct English message guys you
need to get somebody to go through and
edit those oh I see I see you have to go
to one yeah yes yeah well the number of
alternatives must be it is not the case
of that that's that is that the case I
think I can translate that from friends
but it's not correct okay all right so
can you get it like no sentence that's
pretty the next one highlighted sentence
yes this has a bit something about the
design as well that you need to tell the
number of question before ok so what is
that structure let's do an input form of
that yeah and why does it give an error
over on the right-hand side one okay
no so that's a string with it that's
that's exactly the thing I was talking
about an embedded style information
inside the string which is fairly
grotesque but you know if it's a string
it's a string
I don't think that's really the right
way to do it I I think the right way to
do it is with text element stuff yes
let's let's look at in the case of text
structure your quick brown fox let's
look at the text structure of the quick
brown fox let's take that string and say
text structure of it and then let's take
a look at what that looks like because I
I think that's what we're gonna want to
turn okay so you know we've got multiple
things like this the sequence alignment
thing is another case a little bit like
this why is this taking forever yeah
someone on the live stream is pointing
out that the name of this function
should be highlight text just like
highlight image and you're absolutely
correct um okay what is this doing is
this the head branch build yes well who
knows but that looks like a problem okay
very case that should that will be
something that has nested text element
so much
that's in country okay but let's move on
to that some later parts of your you
know using desktop hmm okay let's so one
of the issues is you know how decorated
is the stuff returned by these NLP
functions and I think that in general we
should be using all this text element
stuff and make it decorated you know
it's much more likely to be actually
computable with if we do that okay now
look at the input form of that didn't do
oh my foot ensign okay well okay yeah so
this is a hierarchical structure
so okay imagine you have a piece of text
and you are trying to indicate where
there are countries in it okay yes you
doing the UM the question is how do you
structure that text so for example the
case of sequence alignment as you saw
it's mostly the main you know the string
where both sides agree and then there
are little sub lists where this where
the strings don't agree right
mm-hmm okay so that's one way of
indicating something special so for
instance what we could do I'm not
necessarily saying it's correct is we
could have something where the result is
a list
I don't like that very much where it's a
list where it contains the main text as
a string broken up by things that say
text elements are blah comment country
mm-hmm I seen so you start with normal
string like the quick and and certainly
you have a text element here yes a I
don't like this very much I think we're
better off thinking about the way that
this nested text element structure who
Jerome what do you think here I mean in
terms of the way these things are going
to be used people are going to want to
you know pull out so a typical thing
will be curly okay you take sentiment on
the outside I think so but let's take a
typical example okay so we're saying
there are countries in this text okay
show me the context well I mean we've
got a way to do that specifically in
text cases don't we we've got something
which says show me all sentences that
contain the country containing yes yes
yes yes right but the question is is
that the only thing one's gonna want to
do and if one got it out as a text
element structure how easy would it be
and the answer is if you broke it into
sentences right if the outer text
element contain the sequence of
sentences and then some of those
sentences had you know in our country
text elements it would be tolerably easy
to take that apart mm-hm
okay let's keep going down your agenda
because we've got more things yeah so it
calls for function maybe text contents
as well don't have yet friends new type
of water filtration actually we believe
that we should not have any type for
wordpress punctuation it's a very
classic operation so at some point we
thought about something we call it but
now I believe that the organization but
yeah it's what organization like the in
NLP normally you process the sentences
to get both words and punctuation as
tokens as
people are called organization why don't
we have a thing called token instead of
just word okay that's that's surprising
okay okay I don't know token is very
large like it could mean a character or
sub-community when they speak of token
this week about that I personally found
it to be clear because what is it for
people are not in any of the communities
it's like what's a token can be anything
okay so what we think word plus
punctuation should be called we don't
have to create a new type like like
that's maybe it's an it's enough to be
able to do this you know word work about
actuation you help foundation we have
punctuation yes so in fair enough
already talked about punctuation doesn't
seem terrible to me we might switch the
tokenizer to use stem for tokenizer
bridge quite java and so of course with
a problem hopeless that comes with such
as yeah right right we're really trying
to avoid using java for these things
okay okay so there's no i mean i mean
from a recent engineering point of view
is there a a well first of all is there
a version that's in c second of all if
all else fails it's presumably rather
standalone java and could be translated
into c
mmm-hmm automatically I see let's define
another solution we have to find our
solution I agree I mean there's even
1040s of the only tokenizer that exist
so right now this is a neuron that based
tokenizer at this point yes so that's
the old-fashioned tokenizer statistical
yeah I understand but isn't there
wasn't there a bunch of progress made
recently on multilingual tokenizer z' i
mean there's certainly part of speech
tagging right yeah yeah which is done
with with you know standard modern
neural nets yes yes there was some
progress I think yeah Google released
something of this kind my question is in
okay so when you say so text word is
what are we doing right now for text
word is that our own tokenizer is that
yes a bunch of projects or is it is it
no no no it's reg X and it's the text
sentence that use machine learning
certain your net but take some times you
know in order to take the decision is it
abbreviation it's you know right now
which will train like two years ago or
something exactly exactly
okay so why are we not doing our own I
mean how hard is this problem and how I
mean what's the main issue the main
issue is hyphenation and stuff like this
and for example yes which by the way we
don't have a clear definition about what
a word is I remember we design me long
ago we were kind of confusing so what
should be a word and what we will be
able to identify as word let's take the
example of our of our friend
you know Tom Wickham - Jones okay yeah
should we be able to recognize that
first of all you know is Wickham Jones
the word or are each of those original
you know each of those names separately
words how do we want to define that
that's a good question Tom what he
thinks whether his name is two words or
not but but seriously I it seems like
you know we're in a case like that the
right answer is to parameterize it and
to decide and to let people have a
choice of what they want to do the
question is you know there are words
that are I don't know I'm trying to
think of one that is a hyphenated word
in English
it's heltah skelter a hyphenated word I
can't even remember um ah gosh what's a
hyphenated just standard word I mean in
word list I'm sure we can figure out
whether in wordlist there are hyphenated
words there will be some hyphenated
words um and
a bit different in different languages
also you have a contracted thing like
don't is don't one word presumably yes
organizer will split it in two because
it was designed for part of speech
tagging so it will take do and nothing
wrong I mean that's a different thing to
- okay to take those contractions and
expand them is a different action right
so let's go back and ask the question we
have several types giving different
names you know just for text words
please
okay so we don't have a lot there
okay all right so can you try typing in
like Tom's name and see what text words
does yep
or I could I can share if you want yeah
maybe maybe I let you share for now okay
[Music]
do I just quit
no he go
okay
you
all right so let's take a look at text
words
well we'll pick on Tom here okay so it's
decided that that hyphenated thing is a
single word and presumably if we say you
know don't feed the
[Music]
Redbirds
okay it's just going to do that so is it
really basically breaking on yeah
everything's very simple the things that
all the hyphens are considered linking
yeah instead of breaking what happens I
say like
you
you
you
okay so it's basically just removing
punctuation okay wait a minute
you
okay but if I did a single - there it
would think it was text which is
reasonable enough
okay I mean this doesn't seem stupid to
me there's a whole different thing of
removing the contractions and I think
that should be a separate function to
remove contractions yeah yeah no I think
we shouldn't change the behavior of word
maybe in some future we can add some
extra you know just to because it's
different class of word tokenization
that exists but let me look a different
class is I mean other than you know
removing contractions okay all right so
that's that so what was what was next on
your list so let me see you were going
to demo something that Jerome was
working on I mean I'm good yeah please
could you see that the what you've got
with a larger number of types is ready
since we don't have a lot of types like
one we don't know how many given here is
150 these new types so we should
probably have a way for you to discover
the types programmatically whose screen
is this is this room yes okay great
maybe because it is raising an important
question is for the moment I introduced
a global variable like like this one in
spite like in visual types so to list
all those things what is d after check
it says D all right programming language
which can be specified with entities
also that's really weird
oh gosh that's that's really weird okay
so back up and let's see what this
actually does okay so I'm finding all
the entities I can with my main neural
network so it's taking for example two
given names a person and sorry x case
we'll take the sublist expect the user
and only point at them and one question
also is whether we introduce a type for
all of these entities or not because for
the moment even ask for country language
it is this is the list of all the
entities that I'm recognizing with the
same network okay and how does that
relate to the complete list of entities
that we have linguistics for it's a fair
fraction I think half of them know
respect to what like how many of the
entities and for example interpreter
types yeah I think there's like
interpreter types it's when you want do
you not cover it clearly all the
computed stuff you don't cover
yeah I'm not covering half of them
actually but which half I mean the the
like exoplanet or something you're
probably not covering that there are a
lot of things about food we're actually
I should yeah here is the thing that the
approach that they took to make the data
set was not relevant disease later the
food stuff could be a detonator yeah but
some of these things are very different
these are not really natural language
right things like icd-9 classifications
out well I mean they could occur in
running text all right let's go back to
what exactly you're doing here so you've
got something where you're could you
scroll down to your thing here okay so
what is that structure that you're
generating and is that a bunch of text
elements in that output Yates to roll
she's exactly yeah I think it's just
yeah just a row and we start
this is just internal stuff too yeah so
this is where we would really want to
use the text element mechanism but hmm
did you understand the point that's the
same as sewers with sequence alignment
that you've got stuff that it's just
there for position so to speak in other
words the untagged pieces and then
you've got parts that are there with
tagging get what I'm saying hmm so the
question is how do we set that up but
also you have to that there is an
overlap like it can be enough for
example boss or person this one is given
name surnames so if you use a flat it's
not that simple
I understand you're saying that there's
a that there are pieces that can be well
then that let it be there on line three
that's a single token right it's not
three separate movies let it and be know
your and so the issue is we've got to be
able to represent potentially nested
things where I mean we have that in the
chart print mechanisms in the wolf's
mouth for positi bugging system I don't
know how those are represented I mean
they may be in the case that is
primarily for output um chart print and
though somebody like Jeremy Michaelson
would know all about it
I'm not optimistic that it's going to be
revealing for this I think it's the
thing that is built primarily for
debugging output um okay but but you
understand the issue right so we've got
we've got three types of things here
we've got things that are tagged so if
we look at text structure right we've
got a bunch of nested text elements
right okay now none of those nested
those all those nested text elements are
tagged with something and none of them
okay I'm trying to understand how we
would do the tagging so for example
let's imagine that um you know Etienne
Bernard is a single you know is a single
person with that name but also Etienne
is a given name but now it might be both
a given name and a surname in this case
it might be recognized as a surname
right so the question is what would be
the structure that represents that good
what I'm asking
yes no okay that's something we have to
figure out so let's scroll down let's
see a little bit more stuff of what you
have so that's that's a demo yeah and
when you yeah it's complicated when you
have also a partial overlap indeed
indeed during of sex cases all about a
new function that will take everything
no we're talking about both things
because we've got it they've got to work
the same way yeah uh I think the
highlighted stuff from text cases is
probably nothing should be okay so let's
let's
okay can you unsure all right so so the
main issue here is right we've got text
structure which is
okay so text structure what Oh text this
is I'm now running some prototype build
I think so this may or may not to help
me I'm not um I don't know what's
happening here why is there no loading
indicator there we go okay so this has
the feature that it has tagging here
with text elements everything is tagged
but some things are hierarchically
tagged nothing is tagged twice here am I
making sense yeah so the issue that
you're raising is how does one represent
something where there is tagging where
there's overlapping tagging right well
what is one gonna do with it the divs
are my question so for example yeah if I
were to take this you know by the way I
don't know what that background noise it
would be really good to not have it um
so this is some kind of tree structure
and our trees system that's coming would
be able to take this tree structure and
do something with it but I don't know
what you want to do like for example
let's say okay let's just understand
what it would take to root to extract
every prepositional phrase from here
right I think it's kind of a mess what
would we actually do to get that I mean
yeah let's think this case is you know
much better exactly what this is doing
yeah I understand but what this
particular thing you know this is
something let's imagine we want to do an
operation on this how would what will we
actually do well let's take the text
cases case right let's imagine you've
got this tagged in various ways so we've
got text cases and we've looked for
well the noun version seems to be
horrifying but anyway let's try verb
here um okay
that's correct at least um so so what so
what are you gonna do with it given that
you've tagged the verb here not making
sense what is what's the next step in
the processing pipeline sure um yeah you
can use this as features along with
words to do an LP desk yeah what NLP
tasks that's that's my point
I mean my point is documents okay well
so but let's talk about that task
because that task is not one you know
okay searching for for special document
will be yeah yeah I think I think on
this function and mostly I don't think
there's this such a big pipeline after
that you know it can be can be a word
flower it can be literally a human that
will get the information and like for
machine learning processing you would
rather use internal neural network of
text cases as a feature extractor okay
so if I say text cases of this comic
country okay
and in fact if I say text cases of that
country arrow entity right
interpretation is that what we're
calling it yeah I wish it also completed
why it wasn't the autocomplete are
working in that case yeah this is what I
mean when you have the arrow when you
have a rule you only compete for the
type but not for the well it should be
able to complete for the right hand side
yeah yes we that's crazy that that gets
come out comes out as a country there
he's a contractor if not it's not for me
it was changed the way that if
interpreters still is doing that then
it's a bug and that should be tracked
through who's thank ya could you please
get that track through because that
isn't right mm-hmm that was changed a
while ago okay so what this did though
was somewhat useful right it's saying
you know what countries are in this
article right so if for example I could
go and look at you know let me let me do
something real okay let me say let's say
this text cases for example let's say
that what I wanted to do in my pipeline
was make um hold on so I want to do text
case this country our interpretation
you
want to do it for let's say let's get
some elements um now let's go 50-55 no
idea what those are okay so now
presumably if I do this let's see what
happens
Splore okay what happened them me see
not available so I probably we could be
their data many times missing but it
shouldn't for that I if I take that when
I put in that entity it should do just
fine so let's see what happens
oh that's crazy huh that's another bug
because if there is decoration rights to
link these two right right there is so
that should work there but that system
can you report that bug I'm very
surprised by that bug mm-hmm okay so
that's pretty cool what that just did
right so if we say if we get rid of the
world things there if we delete cases
that comma I'm just I'm just trying to
understand a use case that we can look
at okay also something that could wind
up in the documentation okay and now I
say let's say geo list plot
um and this will hopefully show me you
know Sushma can you comment that that
thing down the bottom there should be it
should have had dot dots but it only has
a single dot oh now it's doing three
dots I don't know why I think it is
incrementing till four dots oh I see but
it says one the one dot looks weird it
should I start at two dots okay
hadn't thought of that well that's
pretty cool right so that's a that's an
example of a semi real use case right
for this so let's talk about and and for
example classifying you know these
documents based on what countries appear
in them and things like that right I
understand that use case and that seems
to work you know design wise that seems
to work quite nicely
makes sense yep
so now for human purposes getting out
the particular sentences you know what
sentence did Thailand appear in for
instance is this this is not your code
here right Jerome this is this is older
code this is no that's eleven three so
what's that
see I've already started to do bug fixes
between eleven point two and eleven
point three but it's mostly the previous
version yeah but this is really very
nice what it did here um so again
walk me through use cases I mean this is
clearly useful right to get one of those
sentences out with tagging that can be
seen by human is also useful I'm not
sure what the machine is going to do
with that tagging Jerome can you comment
on that please
you probably underneath a geographical
map no no no no no no no no after the
tagging what what kind of program we
could run after that me and I'm not a
big fan of I don't see that many use
case of programmatically accessing the
results well okay listen listen there
the traditional story of NLP you know
always used to be oh my gosh we have to
you know do parsing we have to figure
out all kinds of computational
linguistics stuff and then it will be
wonderful but actually I haven't seen
very many use cases for that I've seen
entity extraction and what else yeah I
mean they can be used as feature
extractor
so once you have a network that can do
the entity recognition for example all
the grammatical parsing or you can use
that as feature exists that works can
cut them into matrix factor to be using
the for some other tasks I rarely see
a task that is solved by first doing a
passing let's say and then acting on the
past three you see what I mean or we
pass so usually it's this there's no
symbolic interface usually usually the
thing and you still have a numeric at
the phase two to go through your task so
for me it's mostly like the visualizing
don't think for me it's mostly with
humans however except when you wanna
extract things like you can extract all
the noun phrase in order to do facts
extraction it may be very yeah sensible
to first extract a noun phrase and then
worked on that I've seen people I mean
that's some people that I wanted to use
text structure and do stuff with it we
have realization but it's probably
because we don't have yet in text cases
well let me give an example of something
might want to answer alright so let's
say you don't fact extraction and it
says you know you know Alan Turing you
know wrote a paper by Universal
computers and he also worked on
theoretical biology okay so what you
would like to turn that into is
something which might be the statements
you know Alan Turing worked on universal
computers Alan Turing wrote a paper
about theoretical biology that is you
want to resolve you want to simplify
that factor it out in that kind of way
by making sense um and that's you know
that is a common thing where people are
doing pronoun you know what is the
pronoun refer to etcetera etcetera
etcetera I mean the question is from all
of this tagging stuff
you know it's a big complicated mess to
do that and it seems like the operation
you're really trying to do is a
different operation there you know the
question look I mean one thing one could
imagine is something which is you know
where we put something in which we could
do probably with a nice neuron that
method which is essentially a program
resolver which just simplifies every
shoroma am I am I making sense here that
makes the the text extremely boring for
a human to read but resolved in terms of
pronouns and as a pre-processing step
for fact extraction that seems quite
useful I mean are we effectively doing
that in a fact extractor or not or is
that coming out from some other kind of
you know training thing that is not you
know specific because I think that's the
you know ultimately most you know the
fact extraction stuff boils down to a
bunch of template largely templated you
know pieces of extraction I think but
the place where that doesn't work is
with pronouns and things am I making
sense
yeah and for now we don't really have a
FedEx structure we have the same textual
answer right I mean it doesn't use
computational linguistics it uses pure
neural net stuff right yeah yeah
okay so let's loop back to what some of
the questions are here okay so you've
got some designers to use with test
cases um which I think are a little hard
to resolve until we know what text cases
is going to be used for beyond the
obvious so to speak I think the thing to
do with your alternatives thing and
that's obviously correct um in terms of
the right-hand side and whether it
should generate sub associations um I
think it's do any I'm not sure and it's
also yeah a smaller change
from the current design what is a small
change like a change of keeping the list
look the main issue with the list thing
is this you're right that this question
about whether it has two copies when
there are two instances it's probably
okay to do your Association thing and to
leave the right hand side to be a list
I'm not totally certain yeah it's a you
know it's a challenge to you know I'm
not keen to do experimental eyes it
before we actually understand more of
the pipeline to see whether that's
actually correct okay but let's let's
loop back so we've got that now the next
question is that somewhat bizarre list
of things that can be used as the text
case the things to essentially search
for in text cases right yes yes yes yes
yes
which by the way there is a type but you
can also do texts cases like instead of
country you can say test cases and you
put just Brazil well also yeah okay all
right so let's do that in the case of
this thing here
so you have like string type and then
you have you know okay so then what do I
do so if I want to get the sentences
containing that what do I do
containing really or do I just say our
sentence no no no it we it would be the
you created basically a new type solid
pattern right containing I don't know if
it's first argument of second sentence
yes sentence coma okay so yeah that's
quite nice so could I also do containing
noun phrase : Brazil does that not work
each I mean when once we have a noun
phrase it should
um switchman do you know where I'm
storing any of the stuff there is a dick
structure there's a text search the text
structure let's let's start one for NLP
okay okay so you know this is pretty
useful this seems pretty sensible what
we have here
and presumably what we could do here if
we wanted to is to say arrow position
oops
yep and we'll get that Gandhi okay all
right so the thing you want to do you
want something which can generate a
highlighted version of this at least a
visually highlighted version yeah in a
not totally absurd way it's just how to
do that I mean you know to put it in the
string it's really a mess
I mean it's either a string or it's not
a string basically it's not a string
it's a row box of some kind in which
case it's completely flexible what we
can put in there um but then we can't
manipulate it as a string and then for
example it's not Texas cases itself
can't take row boxes as input right so
that's bad if you have something which
is highlighted and then you feed it back
as input it's not able to deal with that
which is not good I mean unless we agree
that textgate which which to me suggests
strongly that we should use in text
element but what is that background
noise turn me nuts
that whatever they I mean you know it
suggests to me that we should be using
text elements and make sure that text
cases can take in things which have text
elements so right now if I take this
with text elements and I feed that in is
that gonna work in text cases I don't
know Oh
or we'll be surprised maybe hit
something that happened okay well so but
it this is presumably should work right
yeah I mean so okay look to me what we
need to do the tagging the the visible
tagging stuff should be done with text
element in some way text cases and the
other text manipulation functions have
to know how to take in a text element
you know
hierarchy and you know clever they could
use that hierarchy in that processing
what we're gonna say that you know the
white space is in text element I'm just
concerned about this that like you don't
have the the transformation to get the
original string from the output of 6
trickster now all that's interesting
isn't it
you could keep the whitespace in some
way we could yes we could as a thing not
displayed in the text structure output
but in the text elements but where would
the whitespace go because the whitespace
the text elements are tagging words here
the white spaces into word or we lose
completely the complete ability and we
just do you know takes visualization
thing where you just have the string and
a second argument you have yeah well
social I just show so highlight image
has the feature that the thing you get
back because an image is an image so to
speak is stealing here what's that
in still image
well whatever is stupid
you
right
right so that sort of idempotence is not
present for Strings
right so that is very interesting so
what do we do
I mean it is look I mean the fact is
there is a way to stuff you know styling
into a string and if we wanted to we
probably could I mean we could do
various kinds of hackery but I don't
like it very much I don't like it it's
bad idea I mean we could use you know we
can just you know we could reduce the
the footprint of the string highlight
stuff in the string by using it's a it's
a super bad idea never mind it's it's
some ok so the question is is it a
string and the answer is it really can't
be a string if it has decorated
highlighting um that means that these
functions that except normally strings
for text processing better accept text
elements in that case - the problem with
that as you say is that text element has
made the thing computable in some way
and for example has lost some of the of
the information that was there
originally yeah in the super easy one
like he's just concerned with
highlighting a string but it's not a new
new symbol
you know like highlighted string and the
first document is a string and second
argument you have a bunch of information
about the position and the color are and
the tag and you know it's not very
computable it's not computable at all
but it's very easy for all the function
that take a string to just take the
first argument and it will not stand so
what you're suggesting is that in that
case there would be a pure string here
and the second argument would be either
positions yeah positions and properties
you know right look at all this tile
right if I wanted to something like that
yeah
well I do tend to think that that's not
such a silly thing to have because I
think that we can't in fact do
um
[Music]
I mean we can't return a string so the
issue is
see the problem is that then then we end
up with things where we want to say
things like a piece of it is labeled you
know one thing is its green or its
labeled with such-and-such and the
question is do we have a precedent and
visualization functions for doing stuff
like this
you
um I mean in a sense
this reminds me well okay let
take a very elementary example let's
take number line plot okay where we can
say
we kind of boring
one could argue is that
not very convincingly perhaps is that
this is annotating the number line but
the number line is a thing as the string
is a thing
see but for example let's take the
example of the sequence alignment
business we would like to have a
function that can display that so
imagine then that highlighted string has
its first argument a list
it probably has to have some default
behavior when there's a list as its
first argument that would normally put
those strings together but if there is
an element of that first argument that
isn't a string then it has to display it
in some reasonable way
by making sense but then this is going
to get messed up because this is
positional this is specifying where the
highlighting is purely positionally get
what I'm saying yeah
well they're already something called a
light either so I don't know maybe this
could be an extension
you
you
like maybe when your second argument is
tails where well why are we doing it
this way at all I mean if if look for a
string
you could just say row the oh yeah yeah
we could do something like that
definitely
you know but it's not going to be
quite as some
yes porn is when you give that to I mean
I guess we have a transformation
function that see that's already wrong
because there are no spaces that
you
you
and again there's a problem okay okay
let's go back again to this problem the
problem is tagging pieces of a string so
there are two ways to do tagging one is
by position and the other is by what
happens in sequence alignment where you
have the underlying string and you've
taken the underlying string and turned
it into a list
right
yes
so
and the problem is in for example the
sequence alignment thing obviously
um
the
you know purely positioning I mean this
is the lesson of the human genome or
something is just knowing
you know okay like how do you label you
know you have to say build 37 of the
human genome position such-and-such on
chromosome such-and-such right but for
any actual person that never lands in
the right place
right because there are lots of
insertions and deletions and so on along
the strand make sense so for example for
snips there's this whole RS whatever
thing where you're labeling you know you
have to you have to label a part of a
string by some I mean in that particular
case the most common way I mean in
practice when you know if I look for a
snip I just looked for the flanking
sequencing the thing and use that to
determine it
not make any sense so it's not that you
understand there's no coordinate
position that will work
right you know what I'm saying
did you understand what I'm saying or
he's already separated no I'm saying I'm
saying if you want to say the position
you know the beginning of your whatever
it is Jean right yes we'll start at a
different position than my right and so
the question is then you know and that
is similar to what's happening here
where you know we're in doing something
like this it's not going to work because
as soon as you do any transformation on
the string you lose that position data
yes which is why having a structure in
which the annotation is in the structure
is a better idea
you
mm-hmm right
but the problem with that is that the
structure as generated in for example
text cases has removed the things that
it considers irrelevant like the
punctuation the spaces and so on
right yes spaces could be a text element
as well
they could be yes they could be and it
could be something where tech
structure simplifies the
right where for example for display it
simplifies that or something I mean it
could be that the correct thing for text
structure to do is to include every
space here
and just have that be something that
doesn't happen to be displayed in the in
the output from text structure
so in other words we could imagine a
situation where the rule is
you
that
if you would just sort of thread through
all the all the leaf text elements in
the tree of text elements that you would
recover the original string
since yep yeah
you know that's not completely stupid
because then what we could do in the
case where you're trying to tag a
particular country the way it would look
then is you know text element of um you
know blah blah blah blah blah , and then
some text element of you know Brazil
comma and then it's tagging information
comma and then it keeps going and then
that has the identity that if you thread
through right so this has the same
structure as our tree yeah system and if
you thread through the leaves you get
back to the string then the last
question is when you don't have a you
know when you're partially overlapping
which I can't find an example right now
but I can imagine okay so what enough
did you do it is does it exist first
an example of a tag
what's that
what no even the look a tag it obviously
exists because you can tag something
like
[Music]
let's say we have totally overlapping
it's fine it's exactly like you know I
understand but it's obvious that there
will be partial overlaps because for
example we could have I mean you can see
that in in more falafel Pazza
all the time right if I say you know
blue moon
Productions let's say whatever that
might be right okay Blue Moon is a
taggable thing and let's imagine Moon
Productions is also a taggable thing
right then you've got overlap okay
let's imagine that we were going to
represent that with text diamonds what
on earth will we do what will we do how
would that would look so we have a text
element of and then we've got to tag I
don't understand how this works it's not
a trie is it no there should be another
construct to specify that the moon on
the left acumen and the right text
element are the same yeah well that's
horrifying okay but so what is the
what's the right way I mean you know
look part of the problem here yeah oh it
could be a text element where you have
blue moon predictions and so it's a bit
like I did spring actually and it says
Blue Moon is this a new prediction is
that which of course doesn't scale to
larger stuff but um okay the alternative
is to think of the string the original
string is a coordinate system which is
what that highlighted string idea was
doing think of that as a coordinate
system and explain how to decorate
things in that coordinate system so in
other words what's the analog of number
line plot if it's almost like a string
plot okay where instead of thinking of
it as the number line you think of these
discrete coordinates as being given by
the characters of the string now you
know the analog for an image we don't do
badly in an image actually having pixel
positions so
I wonder whether you know let's just
imagine that there's a thing called
string plot okay that essentially takes
I mean it's it's a slightly okay
actually here's an analogy okay here's
an analogy in geo plot you know the
world is the background so to speak
and every coordinate is relative to that
background and it's common to display
the background as well as displaying the
you know the highlighted coordinates
making sense yes
I wonder if there's an analogy there
where the way to think about it is you
know the string is the background you're
going to display it I I think this may
be a good idea okay so really we've got
two competing concepts here one is
tagging hierarchical tagging through
text elements and the other is I'm not
sure highlighting is necessarily the
only story because there could be all
kinds of things here I mean in other
words actually I was thinking if we
might want to represent that some
characters are missing well I don't know
but I mean let's imagine we have a
string here right so let's take our
wherever it was
what is that background noise just okay
so okay so now the question would be to
give coordinates like for example we
could give five arrow and then I mean
let's imagine that we have something
like five comma ten arrow
now how would it look labeled
see what will we do normally normally
what we would do in such a thing as we
would say labelled 5 comma 10 comma blah
blah blah because effectively what we're
doing is we're plotting you know so the
most naive thing here yeah yeah this is
gonna work
this is going to work so look the simple
thing you can do
he says
it's a little weird that there these
sequences here but imagine that you just
had comma 5 7 10 whatever that would
mean normally that would mean plot
something at those positions right so
here this I mean again I I'm not
completely sure about the way that this
some but something like this might mean
take that character sequence and you
know do default plotting which might be
some kind of highlighting thing
alternatively you could say for this
something like labeled
whatever comma whatever it is or you
could use all the other plotting kinds
of things like call-out and so on on
this that makes sense I think it might
actually be better than what text plot
I'm not sure so this is a this is
something let's to talk to Brett about
because he's got you you understand the
point what we're trying to do here is
leverage all the the pretty rich
language we have because what this
effectively is is something I mean if I
were to do let's just try a number line
plots
you
enter vol 2 6 comma
enter vol 1014
okay great
don't quite know why there are different
levels like that
it's a little odd but okay so let's
imagine now that we say labeled
phoo and let's do this one call out
ball
you
interesting that should have worked I
think why did that not work I thought
that all these things would support
those tagging forms
hmm well that should work I think but
you understand if that did work that
that's extremely analogous to what we're
trying to do yeah and we could put
Legends as well yeah exactly exactly
and it could do more intelligent things
if you have a big piece of text and so
on it could um
I think this is the right approach to
treat it as essentially a graphical
story to treat this one as a graphical
story and then to also have this kind of
hierarchical text element thing so okay
we're way over time let's let's set a
separate meeting to talk about text plot
with Brett and others and maybe Jeremy
Davis um
and take it from that um okay all right
anything else to you there's nothing
else you are gently need right now
you're not stuck on another thing I mean
that this question about how you can
reveal the set of possible text cases
types yeah I don't know I mean possibly
they're entities but I'm not sure go
ahead what oh yeah okay for that yeah
yeah it's something we should definitely
find out and otherwise the only
description we should also think about
any possibly having something called
text contents yes I agree
analogous damaged contents which isn't
quite finished but but for the okay so
for photo discoverability you think a
global variable is not the way to go
hopeless not gonna happen also it's full
of crud I mean but the timeless things
like D in there not as an entity I think
it's crazy I mean I think you're gonna
have something like that it should be a
bunch of entities I'm making sense do we
have a precedent for that the list of
entities yeah for discovering okay so
you will create a new type call I don't
know I don't know that's right I don't
know that's the right thing to do
I mean the other possibility there there
are things that we haven't you know like
a classic case that I'm not really happy
with is if you try to discover what
musical instruments exist in sound note
okay I'm pretty sure so what I think we
should do for that one is to just have
it be you know document it and put it in
the data repository you get what I'm
saying
I see
this as being an entry in the data
repository because it's really you know
it's a funky list
I mean we had tried to identify things
like this that will be useful I mean
that's what I think they should be I
think the data repository is kind of
meta information just like Wolfen
language data contains meta information
about the language there's no reason why
the data repository can't contain meta
information like that and in terms of
I'm sorry
like yes I mean how you maintain
consistency okay so that's yes exactly
exactly if you're running such and such
a thing I
there is versioning in the data
repository but can we link you to the
version of the language I certainly can
if you say I mean I would imagine we can
if you say resource data of blah oh yeah
that's a good question for Brad ashbey
but that's a that's a reasonable thing
if we can do that then it seems to me
we're kind of home free on this because
I mean just say resource data of you
know text cases types or something and
that becomes that is a a rather simple
element in the data repository that can
be where the resource data itself
conversion when it is called from a
particular version of the language makes
sense yeah I guess we wouldn't do a web
page about that right it would just be
well there is a web page about it should
there be a web page in the data
repository we just please okay right I
mean it's just a list of you know this
is the data repository can contain all
kinds of stuff and that's a perfectly
reasonable thing for it to contain which
happens to a meta information about the
language
okay let me see it yep okay but let's
get a meeting set what about text plot
mm-hmm okay okay good stuff thanks a lot
thanks to folks on the livestream see
you later